[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
and we
are
live
laura cognito here in law podcast
lawyergaming.net
with the legendary
toby from prom matter and the last aaron
kotovi it's an absolute pleasure to see
you it would always been so small
two years two years two years we know
each other for six years yes the six
years
way too long way too long we're talking
about last aura crew to the people who
know nothing about last oracle what is
this game about well i usually say
there's three main pillars in the game
one it's a souls likey action rpg combo
thing a combat thing right so you
exactly hack and slash you lose your
souls when you die you have to pick him
up nothing new that is something you
know already the second main color and
that's where it gets important is the
rpg element so whatever you do in the
game the questing the choices it will
have that direct impact on the rest of
the world okay say you kill that dude
and it will have an impact on later in
the game say you side with this faction
the other one will hate you and they
might attack you but the first one will
fight with you so these kind of thing
and this means that you and i will have
different game plays right when you go
through the game awesome and the last
but not least third one is co-op so it
is split screen corp like in the old
games in the old times sit on the couch
check some beer and have some fun
together slice slice through the enemies
however on release there will be an
online co-op as well but today we are
playing the
uh offline course so we're gonna offer
our call today we got lord addict in the
building he's gonna be doing offline
co-work with a little toby told me he's
gonna set it up let's get right into
this man let's go let's go let's go
so i told you about the three main
pillars right i will now show you the
second main pillar we are going into a
later stage of the game
there will be an attack happening i have
your path one path two that's nothing
you will see in the game later on that's
how i call my saves however you will see
the same area twice but you will have a
different experience in it one we will
side with the one faction if something
will happen then we side with the other
something different
you
will
show those
story branches exactly yeah and how how
did how the things you do in the game
will have an impact nice
so we here we have this
fortress slash bridge thingy and we have
three main factions in the game so the
game starts on the planet of vardanya
which is a sci-fi medieval world an
alien planet however we as humans are
actually alien on that planet right
because the nabaru the redken and the
broken are living there and they are
fighting a civil war in which we get
torn in in this particular safe we are
right now friends with the navarro they
don't attack us they want something from
us the redkens they hate us and the
broken one we don't know yet the broken
the
they don't fancy you but they all don't
invite you to their wedding as well so
something like that let's get it we are
we are also sharing the same inventory
so me as player one i'm pushing the main
story forward i have to do the dialogues
and trigger the stuff and so on you
can't but what you can do is a hop off
and hop on system so you when i play the
game alone i can start alone and then
you say dude toby i want to join you no
problem at all you join my game you will
get the same level as i do and you can
freely distribute your points and redo
that at any given time i have to
interrupt for a second yeah i'm such a
huge fan of that because again not to
slander other games but part of the the
souls like genre and cooperative aspect
that would get me into it and the fact
that you have drop in drop out and have
that balancing to allow someone to play
co-op with you is huge just absolutely
absolutely i'm a big fan of iron ring
it's great yes and you say the ones the
one single thing i don't like about it
is the way how the core oh my god the
finger yeah but exactly drop the finger
where's your sign oh god i can't you
can't see your side oh no we are on
different look well i don't know regions
or whatever yes so it's like a pain in
the ass to really connect it's not it's
great but here you can like from the
start to the beginning hop on hop off
just out of curiosity yeah do
incorporate the online feature
you are the whole store all right that's
the that's the goal exactly right now
that's a very good question the online
co-op is something that is still under
construction we have to figure out how
we do that of course in online you don't
probably don't do the split screen
anymore but how exactly will it manage
that is something that is still until i
love the fact that you're doing it
though so one last thing because before
we are attacking you see these are all
navarro soldiers they are not attacking
us they are fighting against the rat
cans who are invading that place right
now just out of curiosity
to clap one of these people
right well uh not this time
unfortunately but who knows
who knows stop being aggressive pay
attention to toby
one last thing before we go so like an
ring or most of the dark souls games if
you tap the trigger once you lock to
your opponent
however you there's no opponent so you
don't see that one thing i want to show
which is really cool is the co-op
element because i just love it i have a
weapon that has a special attack which
is the special attacker on the back
button here
when i zap you you don't take any damage
but we have this link in between us and
if we get
if we catch someone in between we zap
them to death
and this is the co-op element again
we we have to jump around we have to we
have to cooperate we have to coordinate
you have to run in the front i will run
behind you i would say go left go right
so it's not like everyone for himself
and just survive it really we have to
work together to like benefit from the
core element now toby that minus one was
that like his magic abilities going down
the manners coming up yeah correct thank
you be careful when we jump over here
not to get hit mid-air because we're
then dropping through the water
uh now we can jump
because though i can i can revive you
once you're down but i can't
bring you up the
from the
water i'm driving you can't go down like
a people drown too so let's run in
there's a red on the right side be
careful let's try and zap wow
it's easy no problem at all
i'm still locked to you so i'm waiting
what you're doing okay zap you again
nice that is so satisfying oh god i got
hit from the back be careful
when oh it killed you can revive me and
the other and vice versa i can
you that's all i was going to ask just
to clarify
when the host dies in the car no no no
no
no
nothing happens
no no no and in the ring
in the end ring everyone gets kicked out
right i hate what they do i hate that as
well i got hit by the catapult so be
careful yeah 102 head at home all right
let's go
i'm just jumping over the roof here nice
like the assassin i am
with with b you can run
oh good
quick enough looking really good now
what what engine are we using what's
this one is this is that unity it's
unreal it's unrealistic
let me just trigger that
let's try to do the zap thing again zabi
zap don't get hit by the arrows
careful now the pla it's interesting i
love the platforming aspect yeah i like
it as well okay let's go
zabit is that nobody's up and where's
the red there's the red
that's a very tough red so there you go
nice
i zapped you you believe that me there
you go
oh no
oh oh god i got hit in the back because
there's there's postures there there's
no enemies there yeah yeah i can't i
can't believe them but i can try to
shoot them oh i can't see i'm casting
slower than they are shooting so i need
i need you to take care of them but i
can take off take care of this guy there
let's get up there oh shoot
i like that nice nice now from like the
skill tree standpoint stuff like what
any type of specific builds you can do
at last oracle you know um yeah it's a
like uh stats based thing so there's no
like uh like a class
system more attributes exactly exactly
exactly but the cool or the interesting
thing is if you say i don't like the
stats i have right now you just unlock
of me i invite you again and you can
again assign all the points the way you
want nice but only you can do that me as
a player one i can't i stick to what i
have but exactly that's a compromise you
can do this i can't do this gotcha and
you jump into death that's not not
important because we are ending here
anyway just remember that dude here
right okay
white pale
[ __ ]
so cyrus
let's go now and see what happens if we
do the ratkin way okay yeah
oh no
we're starting with the other people
that we want exactly
exactly exactly go to the right yeah now
we are not defending that area now we
are attacking that area and as the rats
we are we are not coming through the
main gate but through the sewer system
so the different areas have different
exits and different entry points right
again
now you have a different setup you have
a sword and a shield to try something
else
and i am a fire mage right oh i love
this yeah i like the firebase yeah
lighting effects love the pop that's
very cool
there's a fireball
there you go it was like choice and
consequence i i know before i see some
some potential decision making exactly
exactly exactly does that still also
translate into co-op or is that
something that is absolutely however i
have to do the decisions so in the it's
either in the through action so
we do something and then something will
happen but sometimes it's in dialogue as
well like here in the beginning the dude
said in the first place where he said
please oh be careful there's a lot of
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on oh god oh
god it's going down it's going down
oh god i love this video back up back up
see this is the type of character that
would get me into the game oh god
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh god
oh god can you do it holding up oh you
go we got you don't jump if you jump you
respawn i will try to kill that oh shoot
oh it's going down oh spooky the big
boys are out here okay they got mallets
they got laces oh lord
i want
[ __ ] so that's the thing as a page i
can't protect you like that but i tried
i tried again doesn't matter we just
spawn here let's go again go again let's
go again there's my my experience there
oh there's someone attacking me
of course if the both of us die then the
enemies respawn if just one of us dies
and
you respond yourself nice then they
don't respawn nice right but
to not abuse the system when you respond
yourself without me dying your um your
flask won't be replenished
so otherwise you could sacrifice
yourself just to heal and that is
nothing we want you to do we got to stop
people from trying to exploit exactly
so i mean some exploits are fun but some
are not so exact we don't want to break
the game so as far as like gameplay
hours at lane what are you guys looking
at potentially for last hour
i'd say it's somewhere between
10 to 15 hours 15 to 20 hours somewhere
there um but um the game is designed to
have a replay value so
oh i'm getting you up there we go
since you have the different ways and oh
shoot there's the guy coming up oh yeah
that's the big ball you come quick quick
quick quick quick quick quick quick
did you get here oh no he did oh god oh
no okay i have to get him wait a second
don't jump don't jump don't jump i get
you
i get you nice he has no shield so i can
shoot him from distance i love that nice
all right we got to get that now i get
you there we go addicts don't die on me
bro not yet
i need you
alright how's that clash of player man
it's really good i'm not like besides
elder ring with the
the shell i'm not a shield guy okay what
what what type of you like the ranged
attack wait we before you go in yeah
answer before you go in and then we go
together so would you like to write do
you want a different character type or
attributes what you want to do yeah i
would like something
do you want to try the mage then you try
to be interested okay
there you go a little swap little swap
action however be very careful let's
change that
so one thing i want to show you now
before we go in there before that
remember that we zapped the red now
there's no red but there's a four gate
and there's a boss fight so same area
different playthrough
the play through one had no boss here
play through the hezbollah here so again
different playthroughs have give you
different experiences different
challenges different stuff you do and it
makes sense because in the first one we
were defending and this one will attack
exactly someone a commander exactly
and that is the dude i told you to
remember
and he is a boss here so in the
playthrough before he was an executive
exactly
exactly and he before that he wanted to
tell us something and give us some hints
or whatever here he's the bad guy since
we had the attackers now and right let's
see this let's get the girls actually
let's go
i have to go melee you have to go
full and
okay
here we go
so come on with the shield just hold on
and crack them okay let's do it nice
do that combo there
nice nice nice
there we go nice we're doing good nice
get that i'm low on health i need to
heal up heal up okay be careful
that's tough so many many of the boss
fights they have some environmental
things that can help you in the bus here
there's the water pool if
if he falls in the pool he's that same
as us though so we have to be careful
there's almost a risk reward exactly and
there's oh i wanted to shoot a fireball
but i'm not a mage anymore um
but for instance there's also a sp
there's a boss like a spider boss uh
who's in a in a in a dungeon and if one
of us lures her in the other one can
trigger a trap and uh iron gate will
fall on the on the head of the spider
and insecure the boss so these like
environmental
traps kinda or advantages are there when
you play in co-op you can trigger them
try to like
coordinate together and enjoy the game
together
victory easy
um
is there multiple different branches if
you do one thing and
something will open up later absolutely
and the bonus bonus answer to that
question is you don't even have to stick
to it so if we decide to like invade
that castle here or be part of the the
the invasion then uh we don't oh [ __ ]
push me into the water
we don't have to stick to that we can
change our mind later we can say
for instance we uh there's a red who
will tell us that we should open a gate
so they can come in we don't have to
open that if we don't open that the
nabaru will like us a little bit more
it's easy to [ __ ] up everyone and
everyone will hate you that's a problem
though what's what's interesting that
you guys have done is you've done
like
like
those hazards that's in the boss
like most the time in these type of
games
they want it more even but it's just
like if you can hit me off the map why
can't i hit you all right yeah and i
like that like for instance like in
other games
you're talking about the castle all
following with the gate
they would be like no that that only
can't be yeah you yeah
the fact that it penalizes both the
enemy you can use it against the enemy
to the advantage that's a cool mechanic
but you can also use it against your
friend because you have to really run in
circles and bring the spider to the
right point but if
this is so cool there's a lot of unique
elements and what again for me as a fan
of cooperative gaming i love the fact
that again jump in jump out for the most
part the different story beats from the
perspectives really open things up
absolutely we've got a lot going on here
with last over crew man so again
when are we looking at release platforms
uh people who can't find out information
about this game so right now if you're
interested in the last recruit there's a
demo right now available on steam so the
people who are playing the pax build on
the other side of that wall go to the
steam page of the last oracle try it
yourself it's a tutorial in first two
areas
and we will be releasing on pc xbox
series x i know that you are happy about
that and playstation 5 that's where i am
the happy guy
and uh you this will well we are looking
into the end of the year we don't have a
release date yet and it still needs some
love we are gathering feedback and stuff
but yeah q three crew four two three two
four potentially another question i want
to ask i know it's a long shot
you know i'm already happy you gotta
call out yeah is it potential crosstalk
or for right now maybe maybe in a bucket
list for the future well
let's say it like that it's a debut
title of a team of 30 people so it's as
a small team but it's a very energetic
and very motivated team however
cross-platform is a really tough
challenge even for the the biggest of
the industry sure so cross-platforming
won't be there for sure
and as i as i was saying the online
co-op is actually being implemented
right now right now right youtube public
uh due to uh feedback from the people
they said the uh the split screen co-op
is amazing but i would and due to covert
and so on you know you can't have them
we would love to have an online thing as
well and they listened to that and said
okay let's try that and right now they
are working on the online co-op thing uh
which we have to figure out how to
make it shout out to the devs on that
because again that is huge in itself
because at the end of the day having
that online component to get more people
to play and the fact that you're working
on that is huge attic has a question
what's up what i enjoy about it is like
a lot of these type of games
it's hard to get people to jump to try
them out because you know these types of
games have a bad ramp oh it's hard
you're gonna break your controller
you're gonna jump off the cliff like the
good thing about this is like look you
don't have to commit jump on you're
gonna use my stuff yeah yeah absolutely
if you like it then you can make your
own [ __ ] absolutely that's where it
excites me because again he's the souls
guy right
he lives with a difficult challenge i'm
the guy that you'll get me in because of
the cooperative aspect now you've given
me almost like this greed fall vibe a
little bit of narrative a little bit of
branching path different options
that excites me and and the fact that it
looks really cool and i might use that
yeah that's the customization
you know you know what uh what i
sometimes say and the the source
community that doesn't like that when i
say that but i i i sometimes call the
last urge crew the souls like games for
people who don't like those likes games
right you say it has it has the elements
for sure and the inspiration of course
you see that in there but it's
it's just it doesn't take itself too
serious it's not like the punishment
where you die after behind every corner
it's like the game where you sit down on
the sofa check a few beers have fun
together and
go on right that's how you get me so
with the beer
the beer as well again the last oracle
this is excuse me this is one of the
games to watch out for an absolute
pleasure again one more time for the
people if they want to know information
absolutely where they can find it how
they can support the game what can they
do so the last recruit on all major
social network channels but go on steam
wishes the game and download the demo
the last hurricane on steam uh just try
it yourself and let us know what you
think hello toby an absolute pleasure to
have you in the room this is tradition
it's always great to see him another
great game that they're behind check it
out last aura crew y'all
[Music]
you